we learned several videos ago that if i
had an infinite uniformly charged plane
let me draw one right here
and i won't draw it infinite and i'll
tell you why in a second then if we had
an infinite uniformly charged plane and
let's say you know this one's positive
that the field the electric field
generated by it
is
is constant
those are the field ions they should all
be the same size
and the strength of the field or the
magnitude of the field
is equal to
two times coulombs
constant times pi
times the charge density of the plate so
if this is infinite so what was charge
density we defined it when we proved
that this truly is a uniform electric
field but what is charge density charge
density is just the total amount of
charge
the total amount of charge
divided by the area or charge per area
well if we have an infinite if we have
an infinite plane
the area is going to be infinite and so
if this is a constant number this is
also going to be infinite and so it's
kind of hard to work with but what we
also know is that when we have a
when we have a a non-infinite plane that
has some finite area
that near the center of it and fairly
close to it it approximates a
infinite uniformly charged plane so with
that said let's see if we can figure out
some of the properties of of the voltage
and and how the voltage relates to the
charge um if we were to have two
parallel let me
let me draw it before i say it because i
think saying it'll just confuse it
so let's say i have two plates
let's say i have two plates
that plate
and then i'll do this in a different
color
and i have that plate
and let's say they're the same size and
they both have area a and let's say that
i place
plus q versus worth of charges here
so this is plus q so this is positively
charged right i could draw a bunch of
pluses here and let's say this is minus
q
so this is negatively charged
right so what's the electric field going
to look like between these two
well it's essentially going to be the
combination of the electric field
generated by this plate
on top of the electric field generated
by this plate and they're both going to
be constant close to the center assuming
that they're reasonably clean and let's
say that they're d apart
assuming that d isn't too big near the
center we're going to have a constant
electric field for example this this
green one is going to be generating
its field lines are going to look
something like this
near the center it's constant these are
meant to look constant
near the center it'll look like that
and it'll start to bulge out near when
you get to the edges
once again near the center it's constant
that one shouldn't have been an angle
start to bulge out
and look something like that
and similarly
this this purple plate will will
generate a constant electric field and
since it's negatively charged the field
lines will be going towards it right not
away from it so its field lines are
going to look something like this and
near the center they'll be constant
and it feels like
its field lines are going to look
something like that
as you can see they just
they're going to be of the same
magnitude and in the same direction
and they also will bulge out there
so the big picture is is that you just
kind of have twice
the electric field as you you would have
if you just had one of these plates
so let's say we're we're operating near
the center of these where we have a
roughly a constant electric field and
see if we can figure out the
relationship between the voltage across
these two plates and the uh the area and
maybe the distance between the two
plates
so we know that the electric field
generated by any one of these
charge plates let's say for this i'll do
it in the blue of this color so for the
bottom plate right here what is the
electric field generated it's 2 pi
2 k
pi times sigma sigma is just the total
charge
the total charge divided by the area
so q
over a
right
and we know that the total the electric
field generated by this one is going to
be essentially the same thing i mean we
could say it's a minus a negative
because it's going in the other direc
towards it
but it's essentially the same thing
because we see that they overlapped
destroying the field line so the
electric field
from that one and we know that they go
in the same direction
if this was
somehow well this is negative so right
the field lines go towards it so plus 2k
pi
and this is q over a
right we could have said minus and then
had a minus q over a but we know that
they go in the same direction so we know
that they're going to be additive and so
we know that the total electric field
is going to be
k
pi
q
over a
so now we know the exact strength of the
electric field let's see if we can
figure out the voltage difference
between
between this point let me draw it in a
color that you can see between this
point
and this point
and what was voltage difference just as
a review
well voltage difference is the
electrical potential energy per charge
if the charge was here versus here so
how much more potential energy per
coulomb is there for a charge to be here
relative to here so another way to view
it is a charge here a positive charge
here because we by default we're always
assuming a positive charge when we talk
about positive numbers and and and what
you know the direction of the feel lines
or what the positive charge would do so
by default a positive charge here really
wants to go up to this to this negative
plate although we later learned that
most of the movement in in electronics
and and electricity is actually the
negative charge is moving is the
electrons moving but let's say we did
have a positive eye on our positive
charge the voltage is a measure of if
any charge is here
how badly does it want to move to this
point so if it has a way to move if we
have air here maybe it's very or if we
have a vacuum here it might be difficult
or impossible for it to move up here but
maybe if we were to connect a wire that
where the charges could freely conduct
then it will then it will move and the
voltage is kind of how badly does it
want to move you can almost view it as
electrical pressure
and maybe i'll do a whole video on
trying to get an intuitive understanding
of voltage because that really is
probably the most important thing to get
an intuitive understanding of if you
ever wanted to study electrical
engineering or whatever
but anyway back to the problem we know
that the combined electric field is this
right it goes upwards in that direction
so
what is the
what is well what is the electric
potential at this point relative to this
point or the potential difference
from here to here well that's the amount
of energy
per charge it would take to move a
charge from a positive charge from let
me switch colors
from here to there
right
remember electric potential energy is
the amount of work necessary to move
something from a charge from there to
there and then the voltage is how much
to do it per charge
let me let me write that down so
the work necessary
to move a charge from there to there
let's say a one coulomb charge
right it will be one coulomb
one coulomb
times the electric field right because
we're always going to have to be going
against the electric fields we have to
apply an equal and opposite force so the
force that we're is going to be the
electric field
so so far this just generates us force
coulomb times electric field charge
times electric field tells us the force
on the charge
right that's force and then we have to
multiply that times distance
force times distance
so we see the work necessarily
necessarily necessary is going to be
the electric field
times d joules
the j is joules
and so what is the voltage but the
voltage different or the voltage
difference or the electric potential
difference between this point and this
point let's call that
va
let's go let's call that point a let's
call that point b
so va
minus vb
which is the voltage difference that's
essentially the electric potential
energy difference divided by or the
charge or per charge well here the
charge was just one so we can just
divide by one and we see that it is
equal to
the electric field
times
the distance and the units are going to
be joules because we divided by both
sides by charge joules per coulomb or
volts
right that's just the units
so what does that equal so the voltage
difference
so we could say you know change in
voltage
the voltage difference is equal to the
electric field which we know is constant
k
pi
q
over a
times
distance
or we could rewrite this let's see if we
could write
i don't know let's see if we could write
q as a function of
v
so if we just do a little bit of
algebraic manipulation we can get q
is equal to
1 we would essentially
divide both sides by 4 pi k
d and multiply both sides by a so we'd
get
a
over
k
pi
d
voltage
and why is this interesting why did i go
through all of this work to get this
relationship well what it shows you if
you look at this
if we assume that the area of the plates
aren't changing that's a constant this
is definitely a constant and if we
assume that the distance between the
don't change that what we see is that
there is that there is a proportional
difference between the voltage and the
amount of charge in the in the combined
charge in the plates and that's
interesting because
you know before doing this we might
maybe it was you know maybe voltage is
somehow proportional to the square of
the charges or or to the square root but
now we know this directly proportional
and actually this
this term right here
has a name and it is called capacitance
and so another way of rewriting this if
we divide both sides by voltage we get
q
over v
is equal to
over
k
pi
area
over distance
and so what it essentially says is is
that
the amount of energy that that uh well
actually i don't want to go into uh
that yet but
for a given configuration and the
configuration is defined by the area of
the plates
and the distance
if for given configuration if i know the
amount of charge that i put onto the
plates if i did a minus q here and a
plus q here i know the voltage across
the plates or vice vice versa if i know
the voltage across the plate and i know
its configuration i know how much charge
there is
and this is called capacitance and the
units for capacitance is called the
farad
and if you become an electrical engineer
or even take a couple of electrical
engineering courses you'll become very
familiar with this
and one other thing to point out this
term right here
just so you know a little bit of
terminology
this term right here this one over four
k pi
one over four k pi
this is often called
epsilon naught or just epsilon and
that's called the permittivity of free
space or permittivity of the vacuum and
maybe in the future
in a future lecture or future video i'll
talk more about why it's called that but
anyway i'm already well over time limit
so i just wanted to give you a sense of
one that you can con
that you can
calculate the voltage across what we
call in this case this is a capacitor it
has capacitance that voltage is you can
kind of use the electric pressure how
bad does the charge here want to move
here and if you put a wire here you'll
learn in a second that not in a second
in several videos that that charge will
flow or actually the the negative
charges will flow this way and generate
current and we'll do that when we start
learning a little bit more about
electricity and that it for any given
configuration
it has a corresponding capacitance and
then given that capacitance if i put
some amount of charge i can figure out
the voltage or if i know there's some
voltage i can figure out the charge
anyway i will see you in the next video